okay hi everyone so I'm as well and this
is Bertil we're going to talk about a/b
testing so far facts there's a team
missing sorry about that so okay okay so
this presentation is about a/b testing
also known as double-blind randomized
controlled trials okay so we're going to
look at Python code the repo is on the
slack channel if you want you can
download it and start playing around and
more specifically in AV testing we're
going to talk about what to do if you
have a small sample size okay okay so
first we're going to see how you run a
test then for this presentation we're
going to use some generated data so the
idea is that you use this then on a real
data set we're going to see how to
process the results then we're going to
talk about a tests I will specify better
what there is sensitivity testing how to
process the the source data set and then
all the complications that come from
having a small small sample sizes okay
so why would you run an a/b test so NAB
tests the the simple idea is for example
on our website you want to implement
something new let's say you have button
there is red and you want to see if it
if it was blue would people click more
so basically what you do you divide the
users on your website's
50% see the blue 50% see the red and
then you compare to see which one
performs better so that's the in a
nutshell that's the the idea okay and
why would you do this rather than simple
having the original and then change to
the new version and then compare one
with the other because maybe you have
for example seasonality so you cannot
compare different periods in time or you
can have several different changes
happening at the same time so you want
to have multiple experiments and so
again you cannot implement one and
compare and implement another and
compare that would take a long time so
you want to do everything at once for
the the small samples so if we're
talking for example about a website you
typically have millions of users but
maybe your website is more it's smaller
it's more specific so you have few users
can also be applied for example on
clinical trials in the in the beginning
you probably have very few patients
you're going to test with very small
sample to then increase your sample or
for example in a company that is
business-to-business so typically you
will have like a few customers not
millions of customers also you can when
let's say that you have different
locations for example you have physical
stores and in each physical store you
cannot show different things to people
because people are there so they are
going to see it so let's say that you
have for example a fashion store and you
have a certain collection or another
collection you want to see which one
performs better you cannot show half the
customers one and healthy other because
all of them will will see it so you have
to split things by stars so that's the
clustering part that we are also going
to look at and so does it actually make
sense to test on on a small sample size
it does make sense but you you need to
understand that you are only going to be
able to measure if the difference is
quite large to test small differences if
you have a small sample size you're
probably not going to detect that
difference so you need to manage the
expectations with the stakeholders
that's if you do have a small sample
sets you cannot understand small
differences okay so as I was saying the
the code is you can you have the link on
slack so it's free to use it uses just
basic simple libraries in this case
we're going to actually use a t-test
which is quite simple way of doing this
so the idea was to focus more on the
problems with the sample sizes and so
we're not going to use for example
Bayesian proximation or other Bayesian
framework or other type of framework you
can if you download the report can run
most of the things just one of them
takes a little bit of time to run okay
so let's go to the tests okay so if you
if you run an a/b test the first thing
you need to do and this might seem
simple theoretically speaking but if you
actually do work on this on your date
day to day it's actually not that simple
is a very tricky part which is to define
your tests so you need to define first
your population again with the example
if you have websites let's say that you
want to make a change on the checkouts
of the websites then your population are
the users that go to checkout okay then
you splits in treatment and control so
control will see exactly the the website
as it is right now and treatment will
see a different version typically a
small change then you have to define an
objective metric for example in this
case it will make sense to be the
converge
right off the website so if people are
buying more or not so you want to
improve your sales this can also be very
tricky to define a metric that is
relevant to your business sometimes it's
not that obvious as sales or sometimes
it is difficult to to measure sales if
you're doing something for example on on
your homepage and it takes a while to go
through all the steps until checkout so
maybe if you do a change on the homepage
you will not detect something so farther
away on the funnel so it's kind of
tricky and the other thing is the
minimum relevant impact so this is
basically what difference is relevant to
you so let's say that you have you have
a commerce site and you have an average
order value of 13 euros for example okay
so on average each item that people buy
cost 30 euros if you increase to 35
euros then that's a relevant change but
if you increase to 30 point zero zero
one euros then nobody cares so you need
to define this minimum relevant impact
and this is important because with this
you can you can define your sample size
so to detect a big difference like from
30 to 35 euros you need a smaller sample
size if you want to detect very very
tiny difference like the thirty to
thirty point zero zero one euros it will
take a really really large sample size
and it would take depending on the
traffic of your website it will take
years to reach a conclusion so it's
important to to define how much are you
willing to wait to detect the difference
that you consider to be relevant okay so
this is the basis for a t-test so as I
said it's the simplest test that that
you can do
so essentially you need four numbers
okay so you have the conversion rate for
treatment and for
our control again treatment is seeing
exactly with no changes and control is
where you apply the change and to define
this conversion rate you need the number
of observations and the number of
conversions so for example this can be
the number of users that went to your
site and the number of people who
clicked on the button from here you
calculate the variance and the standard
deviation okay so if this is just a few
equations but it's simple okay
all right so then you do and I pass this
test which is you define your hypothesis
so in this case the null hypothesis
would be that treatment and control are
the same there is no difference between
them and then you try to falsify these
hypothesis okay so you try to prove that
in fact there is a difference between
them to do this you define an alpha
which is so your threshold to to make a
decision and if you conclude that the
odds that control and treatment are are
the same is less than your threshold
typically five percent or ten percent
then you conclude that okay they are
different or at least there is a very
small probability that they are the same
so most likely they are different and
you define a threshold to then make a
conclusion okay so coming back to the
minimum detectable effects so this is
the effect that you can measure okay so
basically for this calculation you just
have to assume that the observations on
control and treatments are roughly the
same and you compute a conversion rates
based on the conversion rates of your
control and treatments and from here you
get the minimum detectable effect so in
practice there are two ways of doing
this
the first way is to say okay I have
let's say one month to run this test
this is the time that I have I don't
have more time and the traffic on my
website is this number of users per day
so I have this sample size and with the
sample size that you have available then
you calculate okay I will be able to
measure differences of one percent or
two percent based on the amount of of
the sample size that you can get or you
can do it the other way which is to say
okay it is relevant for me to measure
0.5% that's still relevant for me so I
will have to wait this amount of time
two months okay but with this have in
mind that it's not linear okay so if you
want to detect difference of two
percents and it takes one month to
collect that if you want to detect half
of that if you want to detect one
percent it will take so half it will
take four times more okay so it's not
linear so the lower you want to to
detect the smaller effects you are going
to be able to detect the longer it takes
and it's super nice show okay so
essentially we compute the p-value and
so the p-value in in simple words it's
it's the probability that's control and
out and and treatments are the same and
if the p-value is below the Alpha we
defined then the test is significant and
we can conclude that there is a
difference okay so again we are using
the frequentist approach there are other
approach the version is is very also
very used here we are just using a
simple t-test
okay so this test is valid for
proportions okay so that means that each
observation can only have a maximum of
one conversion so let's say that we are
talking about clicks on a button what
you can define the metric is so the
observation will be people who saw the
button and conversion would be someone
clicked on the button yes or no it
cannot be number of clicks because that
way the conversions will be higher than
the observations okay so it always has
to be a proportion it has to be binary
so it yes or no and also you have to
make some approximations between a
Bernoulli sample and the Gaussian so for
that you need theoretically at least a
sample of 30 observation which is not a
lot it's okay and your conversion rate
needs to be a little bit above zero so
here it says far enough from zero but
it's it's just just a little bit above
zero it's okay and also all your
observations must be independent so
let's come back to the example of the
physical store if I have a physical
store and I am doing something different
with my clients my clients maybe are
going to talk to each other and
influence each other so they are not
independent and in the in the physical
reality that's very important or for
example if you're doing something in a
city and doing something in a different
city inside each city people will talk
to each other they so that there is that
problem too okay so now we're going to
look at the code so the first thing that
we're going to do is to actually
generate random samples okay so here
this part is this is simply to to
generate a random date time between
these two dates okay so we generate a
random date time we then
generates a conversion of servation and
conversion so basically we with this
function you end up with a timestamp
there is randomly created a user ID and
then if that observation has a
conversion yes or no and what is the
delay to that conversion so if the
person visits for example if the person
visit the website at a certain time
after how much time did it convert from
here we compute their conversion so
basically the observations that had
conversions just compute the time and we
end up with a table like this that's if
I don't know how many of you work in
e-commerce okay so you probably have
seen something like this so a timestamp
a user ID and then here it says
observations conversion so this would be
something like a visit to the website
and someone purchasing something okay so
you probably have a table like this
somewhere in your database and then when
you run an a/b test on a website
typically what happens is that
internally you have a software that
splits users to control and treatments
and it shows them a different version of
the of the websites which is what is
being done here but fake okay so we
attribute each user to its either C in
control or treatment and that's it we
have our our data set that we can then
apply these to our real data sets so
let's start actually processing the the
tests so the first thing you need to do
is take all your events and group them
to end up with the four numbers that we
talked about so for control and for
treatments observations and conversions
okay so here we can see
we have 228 observations and 116
conversions for control okay this is
just okay we just function to make that
and then we're going to compute the
statistics so the conversion rates the
variance and then compare the difference
between control and alternative with
your confidence interval so the
confidence interval is a tuple so if the
difference is smaller than the lower
limits of that confidence interval then
the treatment loses it's worse than
control if it's the opposite it wins if
it's in the middle then there is we
cannot conclude that there is a
difference between control and treatment
with the sample size that that we have
okay so we create the class t-test that
basically takes these totals you input
an alpha typically 5% or 10% and you
computes all that we've been seeing so
far and you end up with all these values
which is a lot of stuff so we just put
it in a sentence so take all those
values and make a sentence with it so on
this on this test basically we can see
that the metric went from 49 to 53
percent so the difference is 4 percent
and it's not significant okay so we
cannot conclude that there is
statistically a difference between
control and treatment
so we have our class a/b test that
essentially takes the events that takes
the segment's which is who is on control
and on treatment and then it has units
and clusters that we are going to use
later so for now we are not using this
part and so you can compute an a/b test
given the events and print your your
decision okay so as we talked before
about the what is the minimum difference
that you can measure given your sample
size so here are some practical examples
with this specific metric so this is
will not give you exactly always the
same result but you can get an idea so
if you have a thousand observations you
can see that you can measure a
difference of 7.8% if you have 10,000 to
0.5% and 100,000 0.28% so you can see
that to go from approximately 8 percent
to 1 percent so that would be eight
times less but you you had to go from a
thousand observations to a hundred
thousand observations so that's
definitely not eight times higher it's a
hundred times higher so as we said
another type of of tests is the
sequential test so we have T's test we
also have Bayesian test this is another
kind of test this is actually the one
that we are we have in production at far
fetch it has some very interesting
features because you actually don't need
to define the minimum detectable effect
you can run the test as long as you want
and look at that how many times you want
without increasing the false positive
rights which we're going to talk next
but it's a very interesting way of
doing tests and we can talk more about
that in the end we didn't have time to
put everything in the in the
presentations so now I'm going to talk
about eight tests so an a test is
basically the same thing as an a/b test
except that control and treatments are
seeing the same thing so it's a complete
waste of time because you're not
concluding anything you're showing the
same thing to two groups and trying to
conclude which one is better so why
would you do that basically to just to
control the quality of your test so if
you do show the same thing to two groups
and you conclude that one of them is
doing better than the other then your
tests is not very reliable okay and we
can look at this by doing a confusion
matrix so if you have a test and the
result gives you that there is
significance there is a difference
between control and alternative but in
fact there isn't then that a false
positive if there actually is that
that's a true positive and the same
thing for the for the non significant
results so with the test what you can
measure is the false positive right so
you know that there is no real
difference because you're showing the
same thing to one and another and if you
conclude that there is a difference then
that's a false positive okay so
basically what we're going to do is take
that I'm talking about websites what you
can use it for something else so take
that from your website from the past six
months
randomly splits between control and
treatments end times and so you end up
with n/a tests okay so we're going to do
a batch of a tests so we do this
splitting and we do this in this case a
hundred times
[Music]
and then essentially you aggregate the
results from from those a test that you
did so the the some of the the tests
that were significant
those are your false positives and the
number of tests is just the count okay
so you end up with something like this
so we run this four times the first time
in a hundred tests you had ten false
positives and so on on the others and we
can already see that it's not
deterministic okay you can have
different results if you run this
several times and so we asked the
question okay let's say that's one of
these had results of seven false
positives the seven was because there
was actually a seven here but as I said
this is not deterministic so now it's
time there so send seven false positives
in a hundred is that okay or not okay we
defined an alpha of 10% so we should
have ten tests but as we can we can see
here it's Verizon ah so what can we do
about this so let's check the D alpha so
essentially what we do is treat this
aggregation of TA tests as if it was a
test so we do a confidence interval on
those tests okay and we end up with a
confidence interval rather than a number
so rather than saying seven tests we say
okay between nine point four and twelve
point six so we define an alpha of 10 so
so far we are okay but the ranges is
very large so what you can do is rather
than running thousands let's run ten
thousand and see what happens okay now
that the false positive rate is between
nine point seven and ten point seven and
we have an alpha of 10% so apparently
everything is okay so
just sanity check your code is working
okay it's doing proper AV testing but we
can also use a test for for other things
and we will see that next another way to
actually look at the AAA test these two
plots the p-values and the T values and
you should end up with something like
this so if you look at the p-values it
should be a uniform distribution so
that's you you get alpha percent of the
tests have an alpha inferior have a
p-value inferior to alpha okay so if
it's a uniform distribution you're going
to end up with 10 percent below the
Alpha if you define the office 10
percent and the t values should give you
this normal distribution okay so now
we're going to look at sensitivity tests
and what comes next and this will be
virtual for these parts questions
[Music]
okay so here sorry
let me see generates random samples okay
so here you have an event time and the
delay that it takes to convert and then
what you do next is you take the
observations that had a conversion so if
if the conversion is true for example
the index 3 the conversion is true so
you take that line you take the event
time stamp and you send the conversion
delay and you end up with the time stamp
for the conversion
okay so so if it wasn't in the
confidence interval and something would
be wrong and you can start digging in
for example as you were saying you could
check if if your observations are not
independent if there's actually
something wrong with with the code if
there's a problem with with your data if
you're doing this with with real data or
if they're for example one of the things
that can happen is a very big change of
behavior so let's say that your data is
corrupted and at a certain points
everything is a zero so there are no
more conversions from that point on
things like that so you can start check
those those things for example
yeah actually Myrtle is going to talk
also about the the segmentation part so
maybe you can I won't cover that
specifically but I cannot say a question
right now if you know that there are
certain title stores that behave
differently then you want to run a be
test separately on each of those types
which means that you reducing your
sample size which is going to be a
problem in terms of significance and
things like that you can try to find a
metric that is the same for all stores
retention Python for some it may be a
good example of that but this is this
can be your source of concern there's a
piece of code which is not going to
present now but which is in the notebook
which is hidden my presentation covers
that little bit the problem is less when
you have different types of stores that
have different conversion rates but when
that conversion rate is correlated with
the scale of the store in which case
then doing an a/b test that becomes a
little bit trickier so there's there
should be someone says do that in the
notes just when we presented that we've
doesn't have to do some of that
colleagues that had a ton of questions
so this took about an hour to go through
I feel like we're doing a really really
good on time as when I get into more
details after that that's that's one of
the kind of stuff that becomes difficult
when you actually do a test in real time
as opposed to what we're doing now which
is on simulated data there's a lot of
things that you've seen the tests
actually don't make sense for this
presentation because they come in later
in the test so defining user sessions as
opposed to just users defining people
who log in and log out so we know who
they are but after the fact that kind of
stuff is things that we we discuss a bit
in the hidden parts of the presentation
but yeah absolutely all these things are
painful these things are real and this
is just an overall methodology for you
if you know there's a pain to know if
that pain is actually hurting your test
quality does that make sense
just to summarize a bit the so what
we've been doing so far so so far we've
been doing what is test in general so we
define a t-test explicitly but anyone
who's familiar with Bayesian test seems
like ok tests can be positive and
negative and that's what we care about
we have a false positive rate which is
the universal thing that all the tests
have to have you want to look at admin
matters behavior but sometimes there are
numbers behavior without difference and
those numbers behavior is something that
we can control for that's the Alpha that
we're talking about so far happy to
generate random samples because that's
kind of an I don't think for this
presentation more than happy to discuss
about your own data if you have right
now on your laptop access to your
company data feel free to use the code
that is in the repo to just run that
data through the a test and see if you
have the same alpha that you set in the
test you can say that 1% 2% 5% 10% 20%
you should have a confidence interval on
large a test that should match the
confidence in the false positive rate
that you have just out of curiosity how
many people here have downloaded the
repo raise your hand okay almost
everybody that's amazing it's not repos
good Wi-Fi thank you so much organizers
for the good Wi-Fi how many of you have
following the notebook as we go through
a presentation or the presentation about
the third of that okay cool
sorry about the quality of the code and
sorry about all the typos I realized
looking at that I cannot live without
spellcheck so i misspelled the name of
my company so far so good just on the
first light not no way important the way
I know in gnosis is it clear in terms of
how do we given data we get results of
that test show hands that make sense for
everybody yeah cool does the point in
for a a test make sense to everybody it
was introduced as doing nothing which i
think is a really good way of presenting
it but actually if you do nothing you
should know what happens and the fact
that 10% of the time something happens
is a little surprising but that's
exactly what we intend for does it make
sense for everybody cool because we're
going to go one level above the problem
of a test is that you say okay I know
that if my change is completely useless
5% of the time
I'm going to say oh this is a great idea
which is not very reassuring the
question is what happens if you actually
have a good idea so you could try to
have good ideas and not is that your
test I always say super positive but it
won't tell you something very reasonable
so what you can do is sensitivity
testing sensitivity testing is not just
something very hard to pronounce it's
also a test with a boost so you do not
thing and then you fake which is even
worst the idea is you take two identical
samples just like you do for your test
and you split them just the same way for
a test and then you say okay I have
control and treatment I'm gonna inflate
treatment to make sure that the test is
positive how much do I need to inflate
treatments for the test to be positive
and if you can figure out how much you
can inflate new Millford it has to be
positive then you don't just control for
the 10% or the 5% of false positive rate
you know how much other impacts will be
detected by your test which if you're
talking to doctors we're trying to do
experiment on clinical tests or prog
designers or product managers who trying
to improve the website or marketing
managers who trying to get more people
to use your product these are actually
what the Kaddatz they want to know ok
I'm trying to do something I hope that
is going to bring in 20% your business
is your test going to be able to tell me
this is the case so the knife
implementation is super simple you take
0% 0.1% to 0.2% etc down to 10% 20% 50%
100% so the chew at the end is you
triple the impacts of your test so
clearly we cover from very small impact
with very big impact and on the AP test
that you have you define a new method
that is given each one of the specials
you copy the results of your tests and
you say is that test with that little
boost of 0.1% 0.2% is it significant and
as soon as it's significant then you say
ok that's a threshold where if I
increase treatment by that much I detect
that there's a difference does it make
sense
ya know let's look with a with an
example you have any NAB 10 a test I was
handing their memory you test and it's a
it's not significant meaning that tests
there's no big difference between doubt
it Debbie much expected for nine percent
of the a test and if you look at okay if
I increase that by 0.1 percent is it
significant no two percent no 10 percent
no 20 percent that test suddenly becomes
positive so you know that for that a
test if you increase treatments the
conversion rate of treatment by 20
percent you're going to detect something
and you define a sensitivity test which
is an extension of a batch test which is
basically rather than run a test a
hundred times you run that loop 100
times you're trying to find what is the
effect a hundred times so that's the you
play the test you compute you try to
detect the effect that you have and if
they once you find the effect you just
add it to the list diff and so you have
this list of difference so it's going to
be ten design 20 percent 20 percent 10
percent 5 percent and what you can do is
given a test you run that you count them
and that gives you this big list so what
essentially you have is in this case out
of 100 a test 14 of them are false
positive that's the first line if you do
so changed s is positive so 14 out of
100 is rough it's a bit high but it's
roughly where we expected to be some of
them are very close to being positive so
one two percent but most of them
actually change by a five ten or twenty
percent conversion rate what is
interesting is that for 20 percent of
your a test for twenty one out of 100
you need to increase treatment by 50
percent for your test be like oh yeah no
now it's your difference so this is not
very sensitive to change you need to
change dramatically your result for the
test to be like oh yeah no there's
something that does it make sense
so can I get so there's clearly
something about many more terrible
attacks you sense that this is related
to the minimal directive attacks but at
the moment we're not trying to find what
is the minimum detectable effect so far
we only say if I do in a test and I do a
big hammer slash on one end it's I can
hear something moving so it's not the
minimum that it displayed this intuition
I get there like we had mean about that
I felt that 20 slice ago why is it not
mentioned but it was you sense as
something that so minimal that it
effects is typically something in
compute before the test starts this is
something that you requires a bit more
processing so maybe alternative is a
theoretical computation and this is
going to be based on large-scale
simulation you show you fall that was
fun to do one test and then you do a
hundred times as an a test and you did a
hundred times and then you hammer
increasingly hard 20 times so you start
seeing that this is getting kind of a
big process to give you those values but
those values we definitely on stand
those around the 14 is going to be seven
eight twelve next time same people
devalue so there's a curve there's a
trend but that training is random
essentially the minimum variance of
thought is a theoretical computation you
get their difference but clearly the
intuition is very much there so five
everybody follows a test
big hammer on one and a half see if
there's something that makes noise so if
I make sense does everybody feel like
this is not very efficient anybody has a
better idea raise pan if you feel like
there's an easy way to improve that code
maybe the code before anybody feel like
that code is not super effective
he cut me sorry so that was enabled
exact thank you so much was just
basically spoiling my presentation sorry
I'm getting a little lost your plying
also so the actual data perfects is what
you want to have is not just okay I'm
giving us their time and sometimes it
works you want to know what is the
smallest change you can do what is the
small change treatment can do that we
reliably detect the change so you don't
want to work sometimes you don't want to
work 14% acts you want it to work almost
all the time all the time because maybe
that which is gonna be your honor me bad
but at least 90 percent of the time so
for that you want to define the minimum
difference that is reliably detected and
so you run the same list of steps you
store the list of difference you store
the distribution of that because
actually what you care about is not the
individual list in a certain order what
you care about is the actual values the
zeros are here just because Python is
behaving really when you have sums and
you define a cumulative distribution and
basically you take that series and you
define a reliable effect which is for if
you do 100 runs one minus alpha is a 90
of those hundreds so you say how many
what is the effect that is the smallest
effect where I have at least 90 out of
100 tests that say there's a there's a
difference there so you have the ten of
the minimum of the false positive rate
and the one percent two percent how far
down that line you have to go to detect
something and basically this is just a
version of it after her runs you've
tried to improve by 1% 2% 5% and 490 of
those home runs to actually make sense
you had to actually improve you have to
move the treatment by at least 50%
so that gets closer to me of all direct
profits in terms of intuition rather
than have just a slope you have one
point where that server is high enough
for you to trust it this is just
four images if people care about how to
drive curved in Python please do not
look at my code I don't know how to do
that properly that should be way too
long I'm slightly ashamed but this is
what it looks like this is a lot skill
on the bottom because I'm a little sick
so you have so that must be a percent 2%
that's like 2% 5% 10% 20% and you see at
20% we have most people but if you want
to reach that dotted line of 90% you
have to go as high as 50% chance so you
start having intuition that this 1 2 5
10 20 50 line is at least on a log scale
looks a little monkey it's not super
comfortable and you feel like the actual
number is not 50 actual numbers
somewhere between 20 and 50 but because
we used this very Bloods scale it
doesn't work so well so this is a bit
you running that because of that special
thing what we couldn't do is we could
have many more threshold 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
etc that would be a bit slower but I
could possibly work but there's a way to
do that that is a bit more subtle you
can do the economies while you suggested
which is you could have a very detail
scale and go at a bottom at the end this
is not significant this is significant
let's look in the middle this is not
significant so you somewhere between
here and Radley find not explore one
them one by one with a loop on the list
but actually try to have some small
approach that would make sense they'll
be faster you have an order of magnitude
you have a powerful setting but actually
it's a lot simpler than that
go back to the AAA test you have control
treatments and around control you have
this if you apply the difference you
have the confidence interval for
treatment to be considered significant
difference than control you just need
treatment to be big enough to hit the
edge of that confidence interval and you
have control treatment and account all
these numbers you know them so where you
can do much more simply is to take the
facts think that would make your tests
positive in the sense that the it's
significant and treatment is more than
control you look at that difference and
you just apply that difference in
treatments you don't need to explore
either one by one
every step of the edge or you don't need
to go through a ducat to me try to
explore gradually you can disappear just
take the numbers you have and apply them
roughly does that make sense so it's not
just a question of hammering
increasingly high or hammering in a
smart way
you can instantly protect what is the
exact effect that would love for that
specific test to be significant let's
take an example this is just too random
a test and like thanks for the eat that
test is not significant you can tell
here not significant there is always a
trough and pay attention to those
numbers so what we try to do is you try
to say we keep control where it is so
115 and 199 would probably not going to
change 121 and 2 to 4 are the rigid
numbers that if I'm the ratio conversion
rate for treatments and what we're
suggesting is can we increase 121 high
enough to make sense so the map that was
on a previous one we basically apply it
here so we find the detectable
difference the way it was defined we
apply that difference to a test and we
compute the test so you should look at
those numbers they're the same as the
one on the page before except this one
how much was it before 121 and now it's
148 that is because we've inflated the
test by the sensitivity near we captured
that and if you look what the test is
it's significantly true what's
interesting is that you see the P is
very close to 0.5 because that's where
we said it and you look at the
difference so 0.8 is just Betty above
the the significant difference so we
find the minimal effect that actually
would change what we're trying to do
does that make sense in terms of what we
try to do when we do sensitivity testing
and well it's a lot less impressive when
I pre compute all those numbers but if
you actually run the hundred version and
notebook for those who fall in with a
notebook and run that test this one is a
lot faster you can do 500 runs without
wasting the time and for 90 percent
rather than have over 20 or 50 percent
whichever you draw to the luck you
actually have a much more great
that number might be too accurate
because it's just a random value that is
close to the real value we care about
but that one makes sense so far so good
people you understand how we computed
that whole process for one a test but we
don't want you to Durham sensitive for
one a test
we've been running hundreds of a test so
let's just look at the same number but
for ten thousand a hundred thousand
observations and you realize that that
sensitivity that we've been trying to
measure just like the minimum detectable
effects gets more accurate if you have
larger tests so when we say you want to
run a test on a lot of people but if you
want to detect small effects that's
exactly what we're measuring now again
but rather than have a minimal effect
that is based on overall estimation and
a theoretical value this is based on the
actual value of the data you have so if
you in theory feel like with ten
thousand customers you're going to have
that much precision that's great but
this is based on actual data you can
have you can use a company data to put
as you just replace generate events here
and you can measure ok we've the data
from the company for last two months
this is the kind of test that we would
have been able to fool this is the kind
of change that we're able to the text
with that specific data set does that
make sense
anybody has been trying to run that with
their own data nope well it's a good
thing I've returned Jerry to do events
otherwise there would have been a lot
less interesting the one thing though
that's because we have so the events is
set but we randomly generates 100 or 500
splits and those splits allow you to
define what is the sensitivity there's
an element of randomness
so the 29.8 is one number but if I rerun
the same thing I'm gonna hide something
probably close to twenty nine point
eight but slightly different so the idea
here is to basically run the tests but
multiple time sorry so that's it this is
the test this is a graphical
representation for respectively but
about a hundred thousand ten thousand
and a thousand observations so you can
see more crit observationally have less
of a push to to make sense
so the idea here from that is small
samples are less sensitive it's so far
we're not surprised but we you remember
that's a test if you have if you don't
do many a tests you don't have an
accurate idea of the Alpha if you want
to measure alpha precisely you want to
run 10,000 100,000 a test is the same
thing for sensitivity so what you want
to do is you want to run seventy many
times the best way to do that is to
simulate sensitivity 30 times so once
again do not look at my code around
graph just it's a bit of a shock and
this is for 10,000 observation on the
500 users the same curve you had in
orange blue and green but this time I've
gone for the same case 30 times ago so
you see there's still some uncertainty
that it's not perfectly accurate because
there's a significant event and
randomness but that allows you to say
not just I think that for 500 users who
come on the website a half thousand
times I need to have about 30 about 25
effects on my treatment for my treatment
it's reliably detected but you have a
click idea of how wide an effect is so
you don't just know how big a treatment
you can detect but also how reliably big
that treatment can be so rather than say
oh it's around 25 you can say nothing
below 30 percent wouldn't generally make
sense the reason to show those curves
even if they're slightly abstract even
if you have to introduce them gladly to
stakeholders that are non-technical is
to say you can test or your 500 stores
you can test on your 1000 partners you
can test on your 2,000 first customers
as a small company all these are
perfectly doable but if you want to run
an air test you need that air test in
the treatment to have at least in this
case 30% more impact than the control
that does one thing that is really
really good for any kind of a new
company when the company is exploring a
new space is it says don't do small
changes try big changes a be test is
really good in that case four really big
changes for large companies remain in
the customers AV test is really good for
small changes but for small companies
what you want to do is rethink your
tragedy in tiny and that is a really
effective way of telling people you want
to have bold changes because we won't be
able to detect small ones
so the question is what happens if your
test is a little wonky what about this
what if the a test is not between around
the Alpha what happens if your test is
broken in the way first example what if
you have a lot less customers same graph
same process a bit of time to compute
that but basically you go from 25 to 30
to 60 to 80 so if you have a hundred
users you probably want to have a change
that is about doubling the impacts of
your conversion otherwise your a test is
not going to test it so it sounds like a
B test is not a really good idea for
that kind of change but at least you can
for the specific data that you have for
your website
tell your stakeholders this is how much
I can detect reliably does that make
sense
any questions on the sensitivity test
any questions on the meaning of those
curves any question of which case you
can use them does it make sense for
everybody it does anyone just trying to
use the notebook and it's stuck
yay-yay sorry I feel like I'm just
standing between you and B and that's
kind of horrible feeling yeah that's it
sorry so if I'm setting between you a
bit let's just go a little faster one
possible problem is that sometimes the D
you have just doesn't work super well
we're going to take an extreme example
20 observations which is definitely off
to run tests and find some conversion
rates so there's going to be some
mistakes we'll just run a little
function that is just basically here to
capture errors we run that and no big
surprise there's a problem because we
don't have the right kind of conversion
for treatments treatment has no
conversion so of course could be running
doesn't work
so what want to do is want to introduce
quality to check on the segments and the
breakdown so for a given a B test we
simply define a function ease treatment
balance that will give you just a podium
you check how many observation in
control point observed in treatment and
you have this minimum ratio of 40% but
you that you can have could and say if
we don't have at least 40% of example in
control or 40% of the control in
treatment
decide that the test is not balanced
another example if you don't have
version control professional treatment
if either of them is zero decide that
the test doesn't have enough conversion
and basically I'll put the word balance
would have been the balance when this is
the case so you modify the test with
random segments which is the key method
we've been using so far and rather than
just go through the assign the test and
go for move forward so we're going to go
through that piece of code you try to
check if it's balanced so you start but
you don't think it's balanced you assign
your generated segments you run the test
on that segments you compute the value
and you check if the test is balanced
and if it's not balanced well if you
verbose you can put it where basically
you try again from that so that is a way
to hard code controls on your checks if
you're running a be test in production
does that kind of control doesn't make
sense because you cannot tell ahead of
time whether or not the balance is going
through the conversion is gonna be true
but if when you're trying to run our a/b
test where you have a small number of
subsets you're probably going to assign
them to treatment control in production
but we're going to control that yourself
you're going to assign them by hand on
an Excel spreadsheet or something
equivalent so that kind of control make
sense my goal here is to say if we have
that kind of control doesn't improve the
quality of the test well it allows you
to actually have some computation but as
we can say the a/b test is the a test
which is not very reliable so that's not
something you really want to rely on and
actually if you look into details in
terms of the distribution of the T
values or the P values they're not very
reassuring the reason we've introduced
all this long winded control on how to
run tests what is the AV testing what is
the confidence interval for alpha with a
test what is the sense of these tests is
because there may be some complication
I'm going to introduce one complication
which is the most common one I've seen
doing a/b test is your units have to be
clustered
examples include you purchase have to be
clustered by store by users you're
trying to do some advertising that the
people are flying or fly magnetizing is
controlled by companies who have posters
slots but they buy CD you cannot buy you
know one poster in front of one of your
users that's not particularly possible
so you can only do tests that are at the
user level as you think of it but
actually the
Simon to control treatment is at a high
level typically in this case we're going
to consider a city level so you have
hundred users a hundred thousand users
but they're living in one home cities
the second problem you have it's not
just any how one cities is that some
cities are really big like London and
some cities are very small like stratum
and upon Ivan there's actually a law
that describe the size of cities it's as
if you know and what you can do is
generate function that basically assign
users to cities in a way that makes
sense
that's the actual line that does all the
work because of how that line works
sometimes people are not in the right if
you want how many 100 cedis so all that
is just basically a correction over the
possible analytic mistakes of that one
you just process the data so that you
have a table user city that has used as
a time per city then you can generate
events with that assignment so that
every user but also a city so every you
event is assigned to the same city in
this case we're using as if set of two
just to make the case really obvious one
point three is the one that is commonly
observed between cities languages is at
one point eight if you there's all sorts
of data is a moment function for lots of
situation and you go through the same
Jarett and events generate segments but
not on user IDs generate same ones in
cities apply the same law and what do we
have what happens in this case because
you have one city there's a lot bigger
than the others is that you have users
in that city that are observation and
control for either treatment or control
depending on whether a city is in part
of control treatment of control this is
incredibly imbalanced the way you can
check for that is you can see see user
number 1 has 600 of their customers and
a part of treatment so 600 plus 7 t plus
all the other treatments you have the
treatment section that is a lot bigger
than a control section and for a lot of
tests we have a kind of constraint that
is a real problem you have it's not just
that he have big blobs is that those
blobs are not of same size and you
cannot get control treatment to be of
the same size does that affect your test
quality who thinks it's going to
completely tango test there's a hand
who thinks yeah I know the test is fine
that's actually not going to be
meaningful impactful
people have no opinion you really want
this
so you basically force that structure of
events into a battery test and you run
it and it completely tags your value you
ask in which case do you have what do
you do with this a test if it's not
matching the Alpha value well in this
case you start freaking out because
that's by city might not work out I've
purposely taken a very small sample with
few cities and a Zetas that is
completely insane two of Zetas is really
really high it really messes everything
you can run the same test if you have
the code on a set of 1 on a set of 1.2
and see if actually you have more
reasonable expectation versity or even
better if you have clusters on your data
if you have two tests on users based on
which country they belong to which
language you speak or any kind of other
constraints that will make sense and if
you look at the t distribution or the p
distribution they're clearly not where
you want them to be the way you see that
well this one is not too bad but this is
really problematic this is the number of
peas that you want to have a continuous
version here and have far too few peas
that have a very low significance so
what happens in this case is that the
false positive rate is abnormally low
which is a source of concern which means
that your test is not doing what you
want that has to be doing you can run
the sensitivity tests and you can have a
value but the truth is it doesn't make
sense as if you run sensory tests in
this case because the the test itself
the false positive radius well you can
tell that by causes the curve here
starts way too low so your test has
other problems than the one you want it
to consider so I don't think you should
run that test in those circumstances if
you wear that case I'm sorry I don't
think every test would work for the fact
subsets of users but of course if you
run the same test with a different value
for how many users you have for how many
cities you have for how high this is
that the setter is you would have
different conclusions and the reason why
this code is accessible for you is for
you to run it on your own simulations or
your own actual value so that you can
understand whether or not you're testing
sense in that case you can try to run
the density test it's actually not too
bad it's around 30% sensitive which
compared to the other numbers we have is
okay
actual numbers of actual companies
typically are not that bad but
can happen but I would definitely
consider to challenge that significantly
what we can do is think okay we have
this data that it's not where it should
be you have this big slope on cities can
we improve the experiment by changing
something and that's you have very long
discussion that you can have between
should we do this because it's going to
rebalance the test should we do that
because it is going to be balanced we
have one big city on control and
everybody else in treatment or that kind
of test
I've seen the ton of ideas I won't cover
them all I'll try to cover some of them
at least two one and the idea is that
this whole framework allows you to given
an idea apply to the segmentation see if
it makes sense so you have this test we
framing segment modify with the balance
you have another one I'm going to do now
all these ideas we now have the code to
actually run them if you can just modify
the segment
what about excluding allowed to see who
things that's going to improve the test
where's your hand one shy hand the other
one is yawning a lot of people expect
that to be any meaningfully different
let's just exclude that that's basically
could live into that there's two ways of
film connecting that's it's likely
better but not meaningfully it's not
good and if you look at what's the
impact on the census you rate it
completely tanks the sanity rate because
you have far fewer people it rebalances
a little bit control on treatment but
not significantly so that's a weekly as
a suggestion I've heard a lot it doesn't
really help the test that much other
option that I've heard is called the up
picking so rather than have a random
assignment between controlling
treatments you pick one in control and
then you pick the other the second city
and you assign it to the other one just
like people deciding on teams on a
schoolyard picking that is a really good
idea to have as balanced as you can
teams between control and treatment but
it has a massive issue for the kind of
approach we have it's not random we have
a set of cities of a certain size you
will always have the same cities in the
same control so you can run one a/b test
or one a test week or two or you won't
be able to run the third one of a
different subset so we will not give you
some good insights on sanity testing
because you don't have that anyone is
running
so interesting intuition but not usable
in this case the third one and our stuff
on bats is a suggestion that you start
with a random test and then you swap
them to optimize the test as much as you
can
I've seen a couple of implementation of
that I've tried to do them the code gets
really unwind really fast but if you
want to have an exercise that's a really
good exercise of try to given a segment
define a swap function that does that
modify the test with segments including
that swap function in case you believe
that the test is not balanced enough and
see if that actually improves the test
so far I haven't seen anything that is
very conclusive for test that is not we
great but if you can improve the descent
test and it sees a little bit that's
definitely something that will be very
variable because you will be able to run
a lot more tests overall what we try to
do is we try to say you can test on
small samples the examples I took were
quite extreme which is why they so scary
in which why the test usually have this
completely insane 70 to 30 percent
actual examples of very small samples
did he go around 3% that's kind of them
as you've seen in some cases but run
extensive a and sends a insensitivity
test it really helps your stakeholders
to understand how a a be testing work
they get the sense because you they can
you can pick examples of every single
they have thousands of examples you
learn from to understand how it really
works and that really really helps you
can try to find tweaks to improve the
segmentation to identify the clusters in
a certain way to slightly tweak but
those tweaks will be informed by the
same ABA and incentive desk so having
functions that allow you to compute that
is really helpful one thing that is
surprisingly difficult is to find the
relevant units it's not necessarily a
user it's might be a logged in user but
not a non logged in user it might be
neighborhoods and not cities it might be
people of a certain of households rather
than individuals that kind of
distinctions is something that can
actually have significant influence on
your sensitivity test think about those
cases try to build simulation with those
cases and you'll be able to find the
best experiment format for the best
significance and more importantly
control for everything
you're doing before you run the test
once you have a test it's a lot harder
to challenge the test but if you have
before you get the results telling
people the test will not be usable in
certain cases it's a lot easier to do
any questions on a testing
so your question is if you have clusters
that are very different in size can you
sub sample them that's an excellent idea
try you don't have that you have the
code on your computer you can actually
say okay for let's try to have for the
city's other largest sub sample and see
if it actually improves the test that
should be five or six lines over Python
so just if you want to do it you have
half an hour to go through it and I'm
sure that will actually be very
interesting to see if it makes sense
I've tried in certain cases sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't it really
depends on all the factors of your
dataset most likely correlation between
city size and conversion rate any other
questions on a test sensitivity D yeah
yes it is a pragmatic way of doing power
analysis
yeah so it's it's do that with the
sample with an existing sample it relies
on assumptions about the structure of
your data the beta are students that you
have independence between variables and
things like that that may not be true
the t-test assumes a context yeah which
is why if you feel like you want to use
the different methods of the t-test it's
just a plug in there's actually on the
repository there's an open issue to
implement a Bayesian test there's an
open issue to internet the sequential
test we'll be happy to do that we just
haven't had time before this
presentation but absolutely yes
it is extremely common it's extremely
common I've done that so many times I
don't want to do that later I'm trying
to avoid that as much as I can so the
situation is very simple you have
whatever symmetric that has a lot of
uncertainty and you detect a really big
change a lot of money that it test seems
to be saving but because you have so
much uncertainty you not convinced this
a significant and if you're talking to
people that Association triggers
dissipation so that I don't have this
intuition of uncertainty there like
there's like 40 million on the table why
are we saying no to 40 millions I'm like
it's not 14 years it's somewhere between
minus 40 50 million and plus 120 million
which is you know it's a lot of money
either way but is you know there's a big
chance that it will be losing more money
if the test is not happy so what we're
trying to do is we're trying to make
that situation as painless as possible
this approach tells you before you do
that tell people any change that is less
than hundred million will not have an
impact to expect so that they're like
they start thinking 40 million is not a
little much it's a weird mindset to
change but if you give them those
numbers and you have them focus on a
conversion rate which is a lot less
scary than million of dollars you can
actually just change our micelle a bit
second thing is do not say 40 million
show the confidence interval show the
distribution if you Bayesian show them
the uncertainty as a key part of the
result you have that just before is the
conversation on I'm only looking at one
number that numbers positive and I'm not
going to look at insert that number
which is another way of looking at the
same kind of a thing
p-value is counterintuitive I have yet
to see people who like p-value and can
explain how it is most people who can
explain how it is like it because I
don't think it's an intuitive way of
explaining what it is
I just someone actually likes it and I
know how to explain it but typically
that's just not a great overlap that's
why I'd rather talk about those examples
if I can walk someone who has an eye
there's were some stats at the beginning
just out of mercy for people but it can
actually walk someone through the whole
process without using a single square
root and that is a lot more convenience
if you're talking to people who do not
like math as a cultural background
I've run love those tests for video
games
these people who make video games are
awesome but not a single one of them was
good at math in high school they make
amazing math actually I'd like do you
have a talking about making videos edit
video allergic to that kinda
communication so you want to have
something that is colorful playful not a
lot of drawings on that my fault tried a
new presentation for me but that's
definitely the kind of thing you want to
do the last thing is the problem is if
you sell someone either you accept the
test because there is 40 million on the
table or you don't accept the test and
you losing those 40 million is you
showing them a dichotomous situation and
that I think is the biggest mistake it's
not necessarily not communicating around
70 is confronting them to a yes or no
question that seems bigger than
themselves and that's I think the real
issue around people focusing on the
amounts rather than p-value or non
Santiago it's not really unless anyone's
M&P body that its problems so that's why
we've Jonathan's we've implemented a
sequential test where a decision is not
either you take the money or you walk
away from it it's you can wait one extra
day to have slightly better interval so
it's not just we representing tuneable
and 40 millions is we say but if you
wait one extra week that interval is
gonna be a slightly smaller that
Neville's gonna be slightly smaller and
hopefully at some point that interval is
still quite wide but entirely positive
so we don't know if we saving to
millions or 80 millions but we know it's
a positive number so it's a lot easier
to say let's go with that idea
hopefully we're actually saving the
company 40 millions but that uncertainty
is dwindling because we have this
sequential approach the last one is you
don't say 40 millions because you
randomly stumble in 40 minutes you say
40 minutes because the ideas you have
are insightful the change you made is
actually meaningful and there's probably
a couple of her 40 minutes behind that
idea if you understand where this either
come from an experience I've had a lot
is any company I've worked for and
that's a long list is those changes are
correlated to something that makes sense
improving like strolling someone's
credit card number so that if they buy
something a second time is a really
impactful way to get people to convert
more it doesn't work on people who
haven't purchased before if you think
about it for two seconds that's
completely obvious but even things
obvious like that people don't remember
them and actually detecting saying okay
we're gonna run the test as it is but
we're also gonna run the shadow
test on people who who've looking for
the first time because people who
purchase up ping before we go to run the
tests on people in certain countries
were going to run tests some people who
use mobile versus desktop we go to run
the test in different dimensions I mean
not going to use those as decision
makers but as insights and not telling
someone oh it's 40 million saving for
the company but it's 60 million on
people use mobile and - 20 millions of
go use desktop that is a lot more
interesting conversation to have because
it's not I'm telling you to not
implement that feature it's me telling
you you should implement that feature
but no on desktop and that is not an
intuition that necessary people have
because they just so many dimensions
that they don't explore them one by one
but as automation system you can
actually easily check those by yourself
and that turns a yes or no question into
a iterative question and into an
intuitive insights and hopefully that
helps people make better decision
without having to talk about you know
you being the blocker for large amount
of money but that's just a small part of
it so that was a really long answer to
your question I had little to do with
sensory tests but I'm sending me to Anu
and beer so I'd rather make first along
anyone who has a question yeah
[Music]
yeah in between which I feel gets away
from all of these issues
that approach so I'm supposed to repeat
the question but that's gonna be tricky
I'm not sure so so you we have users who
belong to city and you're saying we
assuming that all the cities are the
same that's not when you say something
shedding the Archy
yeah that makes a lot of sense this is
something we've been thinking a lot not
necessarily for that case but for other
key situation we have we haven't
implementing in production yet this
would allow for specifically far fetch
and a couple of experiments I'm thinking
about would allow us to unlock key
situations the far-fetched price point
is very high it's not a big mystery that
we have fewer customers and company with
the same revenue we have very high I've
adored that event fewer customers and we
have a lot of our revenue coming from a
small number of customers testing on
those people is harder because there's
just few people who spend hundreds of
thousands every month on top edge so
this is a key question for us
specifically because of our business
model I haven't found any implementation
of that publicly and I've talked to
people at booking I've talked about
Facebook on how they do testing this is
not read upon for either company if you
know of a company that has that kind of
approach if you know of a lab that has
things what about it I'll be very
interested at the moment our solution is
as we describe to use larger sample as a
buyers in prior the information we have
on small sample centers and updates and
hopefully be able to update that but we
don't have any guidance on that so if
you have any insights I'd be very very
happy to to collaborate on that just
because we are in a dark at the moment
but this is really I think it's really
good intuition and this is definitely
we're going to work and it's in the next
month
is there anyone else who wants to delay
the beer for everybody else in the room
I can do it I've got a mic but otherwise
thank you so much for your attention
the repo is available for everybody
there's six or seven issues up and if
you want to do demos exercise Mona
happens to do about experimentation at
length as we've noticed and thank you so
much for being part of Pi data thank you
so much for the organizers and well see
you at the where are we going next
[Applause]